[Music]
foreign
and destroy everything he holds dear
[Music]
Aquaman and the lost kingdom
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your man Paul aka the guy who's having a
Jason Momoa moment as the new teaser for
Aquaman and the lost kingdom has just
dropped online the full official trailer
will be releasing in four days time on
Thursday with Warner Brothers funny
dropping a look at the movie less than
100 days out this is of course the last
dce film before James Gunn takes over
the Reigns and begins his new sleigh
title Gods and Monsters starting with
Superman Legacy I think a lot hinges on
both that and and Deadpool 3 in general
as audiences seem to no longer be as
interested in superhero movies as they
used to be can this bring this genre
back to the surface or are we in too
deep now well I'm hopeful that we're no
longer on a sinking ship and after
re-watching Aquaman the other week to
get to get back up to speed I actually
forgot how much I really enjoyed that
movie minus the Pitbull song it was a
really fun film and I'm actually hopeful
that this is gonna be good too
throughout this video we're gonna be
breaking it all down and going through
it frame by frame let's talk about about
what happens in the teaser and also what
I think this could lead into please hit
the Thumbs Up Button if you enjoy the
breakdown and don't forget to subscribe
for videos like this almost every day
but either way huge thank you for
clicking this now let's get into Aquaman
and the lost kingdom also I will be
saying Aquaman and not Aquaman so if you
wanna if you're one of those people yeah
who doesn't understand that words are
pronounced differently by by different
accents then I'm probably dead to you
but moving on So speaking of the first
film The teaser actually opens with a
shot that comes from that movie in it we
watched Arthur Amira traveling through
the trench which is when they washed up
on the shores of the lamb before time
yeah they met his mother outlana and
this shot actually pulls directly from
that film when the pair first came face
to face with each other and because of
that I actually think this movie is
going to have strong ties down Lana and
you do a shot later on I actually think
that she could end up with stew it's
possible that the creatures from the
trench will be Unleashed at 1.2 as in
the next shot we see them swimming
towards the camera now this might not be
what it seems and we will talk about
this later on but yeah this is a very
important thing to to start the whole
thing off now we have a red flare in the
top right and this Echoes the moment in
which Arthur Amira swam down to the
trench and a blue light as well in the
top left now it looks like the creatures
are outfitted with golden armor and you
can actually see some of them wearing
this this idea of all technology is
something that was actually talked about
at Cinema con and the people behind the
film discussed what it was going to be
about in it Black Manta will apparently
discover an ancient black Trident and
this will become the movie super weapon
those that saw the trailer at Cinema con
said there was a scene in which we got a
green glow emanating from it and this
rap matter up and then began to empower
him later on in the teaser we see a
giant underwater structure crumbling and
I'm guessing that this is what this
moment comes from now this idea of old
Tech is once more shown after a shot of
Arthur swimming away from a down vehicle
we catch his brother orms standing in
front of what looks like an
old-fashioned submersible and it's got a
cockpit based on one of the first ever
diving suits this grabs him in the next
shot which we can tell by his little his
little blonde tied up ponytail anyway
according to what was shown at Cinema
cotton Arthur's entire life on both the
surface and Under the Sea will be under
the siege of Black Manta as he says in
the trailer he's gonna destroy
everything he holds dear and the movie
will apparently center around Arthur
going to um for help and the pair will
then start to work together this will be
to stop the threat that could bring the
entire Kingdom down of Atlantis and
potentially their mother dying could be
what unites them together on the surface
we see his father's lighthouse in runes
as well and I actually think that Thomas
might end up dying too Mao went from
Nicole Kidman to this bird in the flash
as well so if it was me I'd probably
want to be dead as well now I I don't
think that's that timeline counts does
it I don't know wait it has to because
Arthur couldn't be born and so yeah that
he is still his dad um and we see both
Arthur and Atlanta rushing up the steps
which makes me think Tommy might have
been killed during an attack by enter
now potentially this was carried out by
the weapon we talked about before
meaning that he and his mother have to
mount up in order to take him down now
there's a distinct lack of Amber Heard
in this teaser but apparently she is
still in the movie at some points
however we know from the Johnny Depp
trial that they had to disclose elements
of what's happening in the movie and
this was in order for her to talk about
what had been cut down I knows it was
said that Mira now had a child and that
she'll not be in the film as much
because she's off caring for their son
they may or may not end up becoming
Aqualad but according to the trial
that'll be where she's at in the film
now therefore it's gonna be mainly a
family affair with Arthur outlana and
all I'm teaming up to take down an
overpowered Black Manta now we see this
ham at home in the next shot when we see
Atlanta behind her some submarines can
be seen with one of the cockpit Windows
being black with a red glow inside of it
guessing this is manda's forces again
and to the left we can also catch what
appears to be the octopus like Serb that
grabbed on before there's also a moment
where Aquaman rides on the back of a
seahorse and it looks like his brother's
on the back too now from this we see
Aquaman fighting a giant sea creature
which he strikes with his Trident as
well as some of the ships of Atlantis
being struck next we cut to him holding
court with his throne where he Jabs his
Trident down on the ground to likely
summon everyone to shut the hell up now
we also see him fighting Black Manta and
in his hands we can catch the black
Trident which again has a green glow
emanating from it if we look at Manta we
can also see this coming off him as well
with the top of his head being covered
in it I'm guessing this may even allow
him to breathe underwater as we can see
cracks in his mask but he's unaffected
bite this likely stops the pressure of
being this deep from getting tomb as
well and it means he can really take the
fight to Arthur and the rest of his
kingdom the lastly we see his other
sends out a call from his Trident and
this is probably the call in
reinforcements to help him take down
this big bad this allows him to speak to
the creatures of the sea which his
Trident II amplifies his command over
now in the last movie Aquaman actually
called upon those from the trench for
the final fight because he now had power
over them that makes me think that the
shot of the son of the teaser might
actually be mounting up those from the
area so they can help by this battle
makes sense if they have gold in
Atlantean armor though the sub that
followed it in the next shot kind of
made me think that they might be linked
to that either way that closes out the
teaser and we of course know we're
getting the full one on Thursday from
what we've heard about the main teaser
we'll have a point where Aquaman says no
one hits my brother but me and then om
responds by saying don't call me brother
great writing and we also apparently get
home at one point saying if you lead
Atlantis will follow Outlander is also
meant to Duke it out with black matter
at one point which will cement them
going turtle with each other it's even
possible again that she might die too
and potentially Aquaman could lose both
his parents in this movie now not to be
a Negative Nancy but the movie has had
really bad test screenings and the aurum
is going around that Warner Brothers
basically put nothing into marketing
thing for it we of course have the
ongoing Hollywood strikes right now and
both Shazam 2 and the Flash fail to make
any money at the box office Blue Beetle
is also struggling as well and I think
Warner Brothers have just hit a point
where they think this might bomb so
they're not trying at all it's a weird
time to be a comic book fan in general
because movies that used to be
guaranteed money makers are now really
struggling to recoup I don't know what
the hype is like around this at the
moment and James Gunn's announcement of
the reboot has kind of left a lot of
things up in the air I feel like a lot
of people won't know whether it's even
worth getting invested in this stuff
after the promise management of the last
10 years which seems to be repeating
with the new God of zazlab whether it's
good or not remains to be seen but yeah
I am remaining hopeful that it's at
least decent it would be a shame to see
the dce you go any other way but yeah
let me know your thoughts below and if
you're excited for the main trailer
please drop a like on the video and if
you want to support the channel as a
member of the spoiler Society then
please click the join button you'll get
early access to videos every day and I
go such a long way to helping a set now
if you want to get some heavy spoilers
merch we've also got our t-shirt line
located just below the video that will
let you pick up all kinds of tops like
our Theory time one house the dragon
stuff Marvel teas and a lot more we drop
new designs on there all the time too so
definitely keep an eye out for them and
thank you for supporting the channel now
if you want something else to watch
we've got a breakdown of Starship
Troopers on screen right now super happy
with this video everyone seems to be
loved well not everyone but a lot of
people seem to like it so yeah
definitely head over there right after
this by the way huge thank you for
singing through the video I've been poor
I'll see you next time take care peace
all right